I think my vision is let's see how we
can enhance this even more and saying
wow only 100 startups in two years is a
small number let's triple that and let's
make that even more powerful and
create an even bigger ecosystem to feed
in to the already very vibrant
multinational uh Corporation system that
happens here in and North of Israel
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
I'm honored to be joined by eitan payet
the CEO of Road 2 A Center that builds
startups through networking funding and
Technology he serves as co-president of
the investment fund friendly Angels club
lawyer etan kayat has been engaged for
over 15 years he took part in the team
of the offer brothers and was a partner
in The Firm Amit Polk matulon later
Ethan was involved in several senior
positions in the leading med tech
companies in Israel including luminous
biosense Webster a subsidiary of Johnson
and Johnson and served as CEO at kamada
the world of Investments is an integral
part of atan's professional life
reflected in his familiarity with the
Israeli ecosystem
thank you very very much for being here
etan
um I'm really excited to talk to you
about uh Northern Israel and Haifa and a
road to haifan and everything that
you've been doing over these years with
it you're also a with a friendly Angels
club leading a group of Angel Investors
which I'm excited to hear about and the
different activities you've taken part
of and obviously your own experience
within the academic institutions within
the University of Haifa and so a lot for
us to uncover it on tell me a little bit
about sci-fi and about your own
relationship with the place and what
what it represents for you
well actually it started my relationship
with Haifa starts at the age of 13 where
um my family emigrated from the UK and I
decided that Haifa is the perfect place
to be
a wonderful combination between
um Hill forests beaches and a great
weather and wonderful people
the state I stayed high for more or less
uh over the the entire periods of the
day I still live here my uh kids
um are have been educated here so it's a
it's a wonderful place of the world to
live in
why why why do you feel that way
well
um
there let's put it this way the
atmosphere here is a lot more laid back
than the uh Plastic Castle and bustle of
uh Tel Aviv uh the the education here is
wonderful uh people are a lot friendlier
um
it's just a great place in my opinion to
actually
create and grow businesses um
it's kind of a little known fact that
the Israeli high tech was actually born
over the years it kind of migrated to uh
more to the center of Israel or mainly
to Tel Aviv but still hyperboasts the
biggest
um industry Park in Israel uh for high
tech it's called matam with several
multinationals uh having their home here
at least their development home here in
Israel and it's based in Haifa and a lot
of the
defense Industries where it actually
started out where the Israel
pitec actually started out are located
here in the north with the same people
kind of revolving doors from from the
fence through medical and and a lot of
the device and the
Life Sciences startups and a lot of
those are located here plus another
Advantage is that a lot of the heavy
industry of Israel is located here on
North in the Haifa Bay which creates
more opportunities on the industry 4.0
side and a lot of collaboration and the
collaborative atmosphere that happens
here
incredible I love it so tell me a little
bit about your own background leading
into what you're doing today with road
to claifa what has been your own
experience with the industry and um with
entrepreneurship Investments Etc here
oh wonderful so actually I started out a
totally different uh realm I uh I was
trained as an m a lawyer I did that for
15 years in some of the um
major defense groups in Israel and some
Investments groups so I started out as
an m a lawyer in uh the old fast group
and then with the office Brothers group
um doing major deals such as
establishment of Orange Is Now partner
in the obit side and on the
on the side of the offer group
um things to do with the Israel quote
um establishment of tower semiconductor
2 uh which is a incidentally located in
the North of Israel and semiconductors
and and many uh private funds and later
on when I became
the mainly a high-tech an m a lawyer
I've been uh
Matalan my main business was M A's IPOs
NASDAQ that's what I did for about 15
years until I decided uh that I really
want to step into business I really love
the issue of Investments and basically
that's one of the favorite things that I
like to do I don't consider that it as a
job
something that I do out of love
um so speaking of love that's what I
established the friendly Angels club
with a partner
um a guy actually originated from
Belgium also living in Haifa we met on
the train
and uh this this train ride
together that we used to do every
morning to Tel Aviv
um generated into a friendship and that
friendship generated into the friendly
Angels club and over the past 15 16
years ago or so
um we've invested some
nice significant sums from um investors
from all across the globe were in love
with the story of Israel uh which we
were very happy to
um
project at the salon
and over a period
of course it was
our own personal money we were very
selective in our investment strategy
so out of 15 total Investments that we
made
we only had we only had to
the right off and it's always a sad
event three companies
um and out of the remainder we had five
exits of which two IPOs One reverse
merged two mnas and all of the rest are
doing very very well with very strong up
rounds still despite the negative turns
that are happening lately so we're very
proud of that and we did that for taking
money from
places from the US all the way through
India obviously Europe and Israel
um and that that we considered as a
labor of love
but as a career I also had to um earn my
living so to speak and I chose to do
that on the corporate side starting and
my medical lasers with luminous
whereas for several years they're doing
a lot of very operational roles
um ended up in the end
of doing their internal M A's and um
and Investments but the first time ever
from from inside the company and not as
an external consultant the way I used to
do when I was there when I was a lawyer
I was headhunted from
subject to a company
I'm a franchise from the Johnson Johnson
businesses a co-bear since Webster will
will very proud to have the global
supply chain there
um and there's a lot of things to be
learned about the fact that you have a
multinational companies uh always the
team that I had to lead uh were
um a very eclectic themes from all over
the globe
basically I was living on planes if I
have to be honest not not a lot of the
fun but it was great to meet such a
diverse culture as anything from
Far East
to be to to the nordics to uh
the US and and anywhere in between and
the Middle East and Europe
I decided after a few years of being a
corporate guy to um enjoying a startup
as a CEO
I was in a company called polypid which
has now traded on NASDAQ
um and um I took a part and uh we
actually tried three times before we uh
managed to uh float the company on uh on
NASDAQ and I was the instrumental part
of in some of these um
trials
from there to has been the development
and another publicly traded company on
the Pharma side called kamada when I was
cool
finally to become the CEO of road to in
a high for road to Innovation Hypha and
basically row two if we want to talk
about that is the first time that we
ever ever dealt with early stage
innovation
and wrote is a very interesting company
it's owned by Nvidia and an investment
company called matian Haifa and there's
a unique in the fact that it's the only
one of its kind that enjoys Unique Kind
of funding from an Israel Innovation
Authority in order to revamp and revamp
the ecosystem of innovation and Haifa in
the North so people often ask us what is
row two is it um is it a fund is it an
incubator is it a is it a an accelerator
and the answer is yes to all of the
above and no two of the above
and and here's the very interesting
um concept of what Row 2 is and what we
do
um because this is the first time that
early stage Innovation is trying to be
really vamped by the government or
assisted through Government funding uh
we wanted to create something unique we
didn't want to do the classic
acceleration slash incubation slash
funding or voice stage Investments and
it basically the concept that we that we
derived actually came from to a large
extent from my personal experiences so I
saw that on the corporate side for
example
um there are a lot of people that on
their calling cards you can see
but the word Innovation and big
corporates need innovation in order to
survive in order to
um grow their next businesses on the
Other Extreme you have startups that
they have cool technology but they have
very difficult access into gaining
clients and gaining
um access to infrastructure and
obviously to money
um so we decided or to to place root two
in the middle to be a kind of go between
between these two and the way we did it
was actually because I deal with
startups people kind of think oh one I
have a wonderful startup can I come and
Pitch to you and the answer is no but
what we do is actually we start from the
reverse we actually go to the corporates
and persuade them to tell us the deepest
darkest Secrets as to where their
businesses aren't going that well and
from that we ascertain the challenges
that
uh they're confronting and once we
understand these challenges only then do
we go out and seek the startup that we
believe can address these challenges and
the way it works is that from the
corporate side
we ask
um them to provide better sites in their
sites and uh engineering Partnerships
and from the um from the startup side
but we teach them how to speak
corporatees
on on the on the corporate side try to
teach the corporates to speak start a
piece and try to create a program that
create that goes stems over several
months in which we actually see if the
technology works now what we do in
addition to all of that that's what we
do on the infrastructure side as a as a
business but what we also do is we have
a hub here in a iPhone the downtown
Haifa in which we have at any given time
about 20 startups that live there and
and interact but we also have a
supercomputer that we bought from Nvidia
the whole ecosystem of service providers
that provide AI
uh services so anything from algorithm
work through various
differentiating
um software and Hardware aspects all
through annotation Etc all in order to
enable a startup who wants to use AI as
a tool to excel in that area and
basically make it solution work and
that's the way things have so over a
period of Any Given year we handle
approximately 45 companies
wow doing this a little over a few years
so we've we've surprised 100 companies
which is a huge amount most of these are
a seed and pre-seed companies that have
not raised money before and the amazing
number is
out of those approximately 20.
raised in X an excess amount of 30
million dollars between them so it goes
to show that the engine that we created
which is basically need based from the
corporates really really works and from
us we once we see that a startup works
on the better side works and everyone is
happy that's when we decide whether or
not we want to invest as Route 2 as an
investor
so that's basically the incredible story
of uh-oh
and but the way we're trying to work at
it right now is actually to increase the
investment size and to gain and to get
additional investors or more on a fund
structure in addition to what's
happening on with with Road 2.
there's um incredible I so thank you for
the thank you for that the great
overview on the story my night and if I
see your own sort of narrative and
motivation coming into play here all the
way from you know the integration of the
geographical location with the what you
what you called before the labor of a
labor of love which I just love
um and I want to to talk a little bit
about Vision if you had to take me to
your own vision of road to high file
your own personal vision
how do you what are you aspiring for
what is sort of the a a goal inside the
North Star for you either for yourself
or for the organization
I would I would uh I would say I would
sum it up in three words I would say
bigger stronger and better
um in in in in the end of the day
um we we do a phenomenal number of of
companies any and in any given year that
we enjoy the fact that we have a
partnership with rambam
good
a major
medical facility here we have a
partnership with the universities and
the technical and we have access to
talents
um that does not normally go to or the
drift to Tel Aviv for example we have
the uh our population that lives in the
North in the North of Israel that will
not do the three-hour drive back and
forth to Tel Aviv and we have access to
that Talent so basically my
um my to answer your question I think my
vision is
let's see how we can enhance this even
more and saying wow only 100 startups in
two years is a small number let's triple
that and let's make that even more
powerful and create an even bigger
ecosystem to feed in to the already very
vibrant multinational uh Corporation
system that happens here in the North of
Israel
tell me a little bit about laid back
atmosphere here
yeah okay the team tell me a little bit
about the team that you have around you
with road to Haifa because uh it's a it
sounds like a pretty remarkable group of
people that are sharing sharing a
similar vision
I agree it was it's not easy to create
I'm a team who is so dedicated and they
work working hard in order to do that
um I will just be before we get into the
team I actually talk about the the
verticals that we work in uh just to
make sure that um that the from that we
understand how the team was uh was built
so we actually are we work in digital
Health we work in Industry 4.0
but we do energy and environment and we
also do gains
um and in all of these we've created
Partnerships
um with uh with service providers with
accelerators with hospitals with uh with
the academy in order to create
um an interested and obviously with with
the industry where everyone has it's a
kind of win-win situation everyone has
an interest in the road to Innovation
success because if you're a corporate
guy and you need Innovation you get it
externally very very cheap and efficient
if you're a startup and you're just out
of technion
um you're you finally get the shortcut
into getting a paying customer and to
see how that works and if you're a
physician in a hospital
uh and you're you were just complaining
about the ailments of the Israeli
um uh system a health system you can
suddenly take this complaint and create
a startup out of it all encompassing
using our AI capability so we're very
very heavy on the AI which I don't see
as a vertical it's more a tool it's a
horizontal
of that and we have a team out of we
have a team who is reversed in in Ai and
in in the medical uh development our CTO
is um has two degrees in biotechnology
he's also doing his MBA Tech Leon right
now
um are a zpo business development is a
lady that lives in the North of Israel
in actually in one of the most shaving
North
who is firmly entrenched in a lot of the
energy environments
and and
[Music]
she's also involved in the helps here
sorry in the uh games uh together with
that we have on the industry 4.0 side
not only do we have
are
our team leader handling industry 4.0
were also in partnership with a company
called sohona that also does
a lot of their own activity and we join
forces together with them so when we
collaborate together we believe that we
created a symphony rather than
you know we could be very as as
remarkable as we as we want uh as
individual players but when we actually
get all the players together and place
ourselves in the center of this
this is something which is very powerful
and it works very very well from our
respect and that's what we're so proud
of doing and that's how we the team uh
are our board of directors are very
strong Advisory Board
uh that also helps us out and and
enhances all of our
connections with with overseas
connections as well
phenomenal a time I really want to thank
you for coming here and sharing this
with me really a fantastic speaking with
you so I appreciate your time and your
your efforts and the great work that
you're doing in road to clifa so thank
you again very very much best of luck
and I can't wait to continue cheering
from the side
onwards and upwards thanks so much for
having me over
[Music]